hello and welcome to the fourth WX
python tutorial last tutorial we added a
file button and then an exit so we could
like actually a hit file and exit and
gave an event for it and this tutorial
and actually let me show you where we
are at the moment and this so this is
where we left off we've got a pic window
we can do things with the window and we
can go file exit but as you can see
there's literally nothing in here
because all we've done so far is create
a frame but the next step to doing more
things besides adding a toolbar right so
you have a menu bar and a tool bar and
we'll get into toolbars in a little bit
but the most probably important part to
any window or program is going to be
actually what's right in here and that's
called a panel right so on if you just
look at your own IDE here this is your
menu bar this is your frame like right
around the edges but everything in here
this is your panel like this is where
you can do stuff and type things in
right so let's make a panel and right
now we're going to make a really really
basic panel will just make a panel just
like this basically so let's hop right
down into that basically what you're
going to do is in the GUI now we want to
have a panel so let's go ahead and just
define a panel as we'll call it a panel
and that's going to equal a WX dot panel
and in here we'll just put itself and
we'll close that off and let's also say
let's say we want to have another button
right like we have the menu bar file
button because eventually what you'll
have is you'll have like a panel and
then a menu bar and then we've got a
file button and then the exit item on
the file button but let's say like so we
can start getting used to kind of
organization here just right now we just
kind of have everything in you let's say
you want to add another button so let's
say edit button
and again that's going to equal WX menu
and then we'll come down here where we
had the file button and we'll just say
menu bar dot append and we'll say edit
button and then obviously this is going
to be called edit so that's it with
adding like more more buttons to it and
hopefully you're starting to catch on
it's there with as far as how easy you
can just add more and more buttons now
the next thing we want to do is after
we've done you know the menu bar so I
would say it looks kind of like that
probably over time and you can add more
stuff and you'll add stuff to those
buttons because like you've got added
buttons just trying to help y'all get
used to organizing these windows now
what we need to do is see we've defined
a panel but we haven't actually done
anything with that panel like we defined
it but when we run this program this is
all we get like we've got a file we've
got edit but there's nothing there we've
got our exit at least because we made
that but we've said hey ok we're going
to get prepared to do a panel women said
like we haven't initialize that panel so
next thing we want to do is we're going
to add just a text box so we'll just say
text control and that's going to be
using our panel that we made then you
can define any position that you want
we'll just say we'll do 1010 and it's
kind of like positioning things in HTML
again you're using like the top left
corner and then size will say the size
is 250 by 150 and and that should be it
so we'll save that we'll run it and here
is our text box now again so what I mean
by that is see here's the end of the
frame right like this is the frame the
menu bar kind of applies - it's not
really a part of the frame but it kind
of is as far as like customizing the
panel stuff right like minibar is part
of the
name theoretically so when you say
position 10 10 that means it's 10 pixels
over 10 pixels down right so that's what
that means
and then obviously size 250 it's 250
wide by 150 pixels tall and then within
here we could type stuff and we're going
to you know make like an epic program
where you can just type stuff no not
really but that's the basics of panels
and then you know besides making it you
know a text box you know pretty much
anything now at this point with using
these panels so hopefully you guys are
starting to get a little bit more
interested in these WX python windows
and thank you for watching and stay
tuned for the next video